you said that short form is a gateway to
long form so what would your strategy be
for that if you're making tick tocks
you're getting the short form reach this
long-form substance in your opinion and
does that mean send people off platform
does that mean try to get Tick Tock to
get your account to 10 minutes which is
super interesting longer form vertical
video what do you mean by short form as
a gateway to long form and what would
the tactics be in that
it means that a lot of long-form
creators don't focus on short form and
vice versa there's a reason I have one
hour keynote videos and one hour podcast
but also pound unlimited micro content
that's 10 seconds long
you can go very tactical and you know
you know a lot of people want to hear
that they're like should I make a tick
tock that says watch the rest on YouTube
it's less about that people will find
you they become intrigued your url
strategy on all your social networks
should be very thoughtful I'm constantly
changing them based on whatever my
objectives are but it just means that
the world of content creating should be
always thought about as and and I notice
that everybody's into or right people
are insecure most of you did not start
on Tick Tock fast enough because you
didn't have followers on it
you didn't start on Tick Tock fast
enough because you had 80 000 followers
on Instagram and you had zero and Tick
Tock and you didn't like that feeling
that's why celebrities lost the first
time around
so like the things that you made fun of
people for on Instagram you became on
tick tock
and so you know I just I think it's
always and everyone's in order like Gary
I'm already on Instagram they love using
like logical excuses like Gary I need to
focus I'm like cool knock yourself out
I'll talk to you in 36 months when
you're crying
you're focusing on losing
the lack of humility
and the lack of interest in putting in
the work on a new thing because you just
figured out the last thing is why most
people don't grow
there's not an accident that I've been
winning on every platform for the last
15 years it's called humility and hard
work
you think I was pumped when I had a
million followers on Twitter and
Instagram came along I was pissed I'm
like I'm winning this bird game
but I'm like everyone's gonna go there
so I need to go
you think I was pumped when Tick Tock
came along I was dominating the gram I
was like that's where it's going to be
so the lack of humility and the lack of
like I don't want to learn this new
thing I just got this that's fine
there's a problem though what you want
has nothing to do with the what the
market is doing
the market doesn't give a [__] about
your feelings
the Market's not like oh Tyrone spent a
lot of time on Instagram we should not
create tick tock
if you enjoyed this content and want to
take your YouTube channel to the next
level just click or tap the link on the
screen or go to
tube1kchallenge.com to join our next
live YouTube challenge you'll learn our
best tips and strategies that are
working here at think media and I think
you'll love it